For the thrill of chasing a high score,
for all the great heroes who captured our imaginations,
and the villains we like more than the heroes.
Waiting 20 years for it and finally getting a good batman game.
For the games that have no end, that we still try to finish.
and the self-imposed challenges when the game wasn't hard enough.
and when it still isn't hard enough, we face the best online.
For the in your face scares, and all the times
you're afraid to trek into the darkness.
All those grueling hours spent getting rare items, and all the grueling hours finding obscure games.
For the countless times we save the princess, only to find she was in another castle.
For the power of the Tri Force... which we'll never really understand.
For the fun of beating our friends with cheap moves,
but then agreeing to go two out of three.
For all the secret moves we show off,
for the sound of those clicking buttons,
and for the satisfaction we get when we
finally realize the solution was right in front of our face the whole time.
For the Konomi code, for late nights with old friends,
and the really late nights with new friends.
For the E3 press conferences for just a small glimpse of the future.
For the cool gadgets that are still awesome even though they don't work right...
For the greats, and the years they dedicated to our entertainment.
For the badasses, and for the characters who define generations.
For the old tech and the new...
and for all the great things that could never fit into one video.
This is why we love video games.
game over